[Musique]
alors vous venez passer des vacances en
zambie
laissez moi deviner vous venez de l est
new york alors monsieur conrad ne se
joint pas nous ce soir
il ya deux jours il m'a annoncé qu'il
voulait dit bon il y a deux heures je
suis arrivé dans cet hôtel où je vais
passer notre deuxième lune de miel en
célibataire
les gens viennent souvent se perdre ici
pour retrouver leur chemin merci
beaucoup à la voix si vous faites
l'excursion
oui des récollets stone si vous voulez
vous plaindre à mes supérieurs 7 le
pilates
on survole la plus grande réserve du
continent
accrochez vous bien à se poser quelques
minutes mais où est ce qu'on va se poser
j'essaie dans l'avion s'il vous plaît je
vais revenir
[Musique]
braconnier ils ont tué la mère pour
couper ses défenses si on est passés
tels des fantômes il sera mort dans deux
jours je veux rester avec lui ça je
tiens j'ai fait un petit détour
est-ce qu'il va s'en sortir il est dans
un état critique mais on va faire de
notre mieux
je suis dans une réserve entouré par des
animaux sauvages
tiens new york je suis désolé tu vas
rentrer rassure moi cette année on va
passer à noël afrique c'est quoi un
nouvel africain je ne sais pas si ça se
passe comme ça sur tout le continent
mais ici à l'orphelinat pour éléphant
les festivités durent toute la semaine
et on ne fait pas le moindre achat
je commence vraiment à m'inquiéter je
vais rentrer chez moi je ne sais pas ce
que je suis censé faire de ma vie
qu'est ce que vous faites ici c'est
comme ça que ça commence
vous rencontrez un éléphant et vous avez
un ami pour la vie prenez soin de mon
éléphant notre éléphant et d eric ligne
harry and entre nous on est amis rien de
plus puisque vous repartez sans avoir eu
droit à votre fabuleux safari 5 étoiles
gérant et vous emmener en ferrain ce
sera moins luxueux aux gars des toiles 3
ils ont plutôt deux
ça faisait longtemps que tu n'avais pas
ouvert ton coeur si j'ai appris quelque
chose ici c'est qu'il ne faut jamais
trop s'attacher
je n'avais vraiment pas prévu de rester
aussi longtemps d'être tombée amoureuse
de l'afrique ça alors quoi sédhiou ou
non ça c'est pas dit où la pente est
trop si c'est ce qu'on appelle du ou
africains
[Musique]
mon fils n'est pas rentré à la maison
écoutez je suis sûr qu'il va revenir son
prénom jamal j'y arrive quel est ce
qu'il a un signe distinctif cicatrices
tatouages dents en or le pseudo qu'on
lui donne son nom de rue il n'a jamais
eu de nom de rue il ya eu un incident
qu'est ce que ça signifie toutes les
informations devraient passer par le
lieutenant stoxx je ne connais pas
personnellement
on m'a dit qu'il avait reçu un message
lui demandant de venir immédiatement et
moi maintenant
dames elle passe de plus normal vrai
chien enragé
c'est bon ça va bien se passer où est
notre fils moi aussi j'ai des enfants
hockey est ce que vos enfants sont noirs
je demande pardon garde tes mains sur le
volant mon garçon regarde droit devant
et ne fait aucun geste brusque il ne
faudrait surtout pas rendre l'homme aux
gilets pare-balles nerveux quand il
s'approche de sa vitre et qu'il te
pointes directement un glock sur ta
tempe
c'est quand même toi qui a disparu de sa
vie dans votre main faut que tu es parti
tu l'a abandonné retrouvons vite notre
fils et repartons chacun de notre côté
d'accor table écoutez moi nous avons
attendu et on a été patient ça suffit de
nous prendre pour des cons ou est déjà
mal en ce moment je veux savoir
on veut lui parler tout ce qui
je voudrais savoir ce que vous attendez
de moi s'il vous plaît retrouvé mon fils
[Musique]
docteur oui quoi pour toi 18 heures vous
faites chier
vous invitez ici je remercie tous pour
toi mais un champ j'arrêterai de couvrir
t'inquiète 12 heures je ne peux pas
passer ce soir tout seul gars l'esprit
de noël à et à la personne pour le
remplacer sur l'histoire ce que je te
dis et tout ça ça très bien donc oui
c'est moi même est très très mal au
ventre ce fait comme des coups de
poignard
non on peut peut-être essayer de vous
éviter l'hosto fais gaffe mon pote tu
sais pas dans quoi tu mets les pieds
il a un bouchon qui lui obstrue le
rectum est ce que vous voulez de la
merde c'est chez qui lui bouche le trou
du cul et toi tu viens de lui proposer
de le débaucher
c'est clair comme ça beaucoup trop
bonsoir c'est un docteur dans l'anonymat
montmagny il avait 38 goiana on va la
reprendre quand même voilà retrouve
comme les mains recommence en essayant
de viser le front ce taux plein
s'endetter sur la terre super c'est ouf
ce truc
ou la plus basse tout artiste il
m'arrive
bah vous vous êtes vous posé dessus en
fait pas du tout
alors de temps vous voyez quelque chose
docteur
le temps va être figé pour toi pendant
les 15 prochaines minutes
[Musique]
epifani
la chine a noté hier
chemistry
[Musique]
m
oui oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moitié
et tu sais pas
[Musique]
chythlook philippe allard lebègue
m
tiago
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ce n'est pas triste non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est au bar
faut que ça aille mieux
[Musique]
un bol d'air pur le texte de m
socar
windsor
et sans fin
[Musique]